[Música]
segundo bloque económico de nuestra
mañana en directo américa de france24
àngel hablando vamos a hablar de
vladimir putin porque se pronunció sobre
la economía de su país hola raúl buenos
días de nuevo pues se habló está
hablando mejor en el cierre del foro
internacional de san petersburgo que lo
considera su propia versión del foro
económico mundial de davos y en el que
es su discurso pues tuvo que ser
también por un ciberataque un
dato de comienzo entre lo que el
mandatario está diciendo pues hay varias
cosas primero que están imprimiendo
dinero para superar los problemas
económicos del país también que la
tendencia en la economía global no tiene
nada que ver con su operación militar
especial en ucrania también dijo que las
sanciones que le ha impuesto occidente
solamente incrementarán la inequidad y
llevarán a la unión europea a perder más
de 400 mil millones de euros el
presidente ruso también señala que las
finanzas del kremlin ya se están
estabilizando también habló el
presidente de gazprom y lanzó una
advertencia a sus compradores europeos
de gas
un conocido emperador fino dijo una vez
tu rival está cometiendo un error no le
impide as que lo cometa bueno y
advertimos a la unión europea que hacer
contratos a largo plazo con gazprom es
muy arriesgado obtienes lo que te
mereces lo que hiciste como turístico el
juego ha terminado estamos luchando
activamente contra las palabras en
inglés en el idioma ruso pero hoy puede
usar esta expresión en inglés the game
is over porque se ha acabado porque la
demanda de materias primas espera la
demanda de reservas de divisas y ser
campeón hicimos y cambiamos de
información daniela la organización
mundial del comercio el euro acuerdos
para la liberación de patentes de
vacunas tira golpes finalizó después de
un día de extensión la decimosegunda
conferencia ministerial de la
organización mundial del comercio con
siete acuerdos declaraciones y consensos
aprobados por los 164 miembros que la
componen el más polémico sin duda alguna
promete ser el acuerdo para suspender
las patentes de las vacunas anti kobe
que había sido pospuesto o propuesto
hace dos años por india y sudáfrica
aplicaría entonces está liberación de
patentes solamente a países en
desarrollo aunque grandes productores
como china pueden acogerse
voluntariamente y no se extiende a
tratamientos y a diagnósticos ahora
veamos ya están las primeras reacciones
por ejemplo la federación internacional
de fabricantes y asociaciones
farmacéuticas
aseguró que la oms está enviando el
mensaje equivocado a quienes como ellos
están llevando a cabo investigación y
desarrollo al señalarla o de mc que la
propiedad intelectual es una barrera
para la respuesta a la pandemia en lugar
de un facilitador en contraparte médicos
sin fronteras dice que la medida es
insuficiente y no va a acabar con los
monopolios farmacéuticos tenemos cifra
al día pero también vamos a tener el
regaño en la semana que fue para las
petroleras no dan y quién lo hizo fuerte
regaño los precios del galón de gasolina
en eeuu están por encima de los cinco
dólares por primera vez en la historia y
usted me pregunta que lo hizo pues lo
hizo el presidente joe biden quien
señala pues que hoy está casi tres veces
más caro de lo que costaba hace un año y
aunque la guerra en ucrania y las
posteriores sanciones occidentales pues
son las responsables directas de esto
altísimos precios del petróleo pues el
presidente si señaló con nombre propio a
quien se debe
[Aplausos]
y nos aseguraremos de que todos conozcan
las ganancias de exxon porque no les
decimos cuáles fueron las ganancias de
exxon este año este trimestre
exxon ganó más dinero que dios y por
cierto nada ha cambiado hay una cosa que
quiero decir sobre las compañías
petroleras tienen nueve mil permisos
para perforar y no están perforando
porque no están perforando porque ganan
más dinero al no producir más petróleo y
número dos la razón por la que no están
perforando es porque están recomprando
sus propias acciones que deberían pagar
impuestos francamente están recomprando
sus propias acciones y sin hacer nuevas
inversiones exxon comienza a invertir
empieza a pagar tus impuestos y después
este regaño con señalamiento daniela que
tanta razón tiene baiden bueno by the
best acusando a 7 gasolineras pero
tomamos dos ejemplos de los dos
estadounidenses que también perforan y
buscan petróleo a manera de ejemplo
entonces analizamos a exxonmobil que
duplicó sus ganancias en el primer
trimestre y sus ingresos sumar en
sumaron casi 90 mil millones 3 y chevron
petroleum en que más que cuadruplicó sus
utilidades en ese mismo período ellos se
defienden diciendo que la razón para que
haya disminuido la actividad tiene que
ver con que la administración bailén
está tratando de alejarse justamente de
los combustibles fósiles